Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new Mandalorian season 2 grand admiral
thrawn video there's been a lot of people that
i'm asking when he's going to come into the
live-action series there were some rumors earlier
this year and some stuff that giancarlo esposito
said in a recent interview that made it seem like
there are other big bads of the big villains that
they'll be introducing in the future of the series
i'm doing videos for all the episodes this year so
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all those we'll do a giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave all your thrawn theories on
the video careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the mandalorian so far just
starting at the beginning here i got a lot of
questions before season two started about which
new characters the show was going to introduce
in the live action because we already knew that
ahsoka tano and Bo Katan would be coming
from the clone wars and the rebels tv shows
so of course it stands to reason that other major
characters from those shows would eventually show
up in the live-action series as well dave filoni
was the show writer for those tv shows he's also
one of the show runners and executive producers
on the mandalorian so he's usually the one
that's responsible for plucking the animated
characters and bringing them into live action
he was played by Lars Mikkelsen Mads Mikkelsen's
brother on star wars rebels he did a fantastic job
you could actually bring him on as the live-action
version of thrawn and just paint him blue
it's the dead eye stare that gives it away there
were a lot of rumors that they'd be doing a
live-action version of grand admiral thrawn
eventually on one of the new shows because
there's so many new disney plus star wars series
they're developing and as we've seen so far on the
mandalorian the only big bad that we know about
is moff gideon and giancarlo esposito has done
a fantastic job with him his character is mostly
inspired by darth vader the references are pretty
obvious in the way his black armor looks his
black space cape his personality his methods
killing subordinates that displease him
left and right classic darth vader move
he said that all those references are intentional
and he loves every minute of it the mandalorian
series takes most of its inspiration and its
references from the original trilogy of movies and
what happened during the original trilogy were
introduced to darth vader in a new hope as the
main villain but then we learned that there's
a higher power that he answers to during empire
strikes back the emperor who's really pulling
the strings recently giancarlo esposito did a new
interview after episode 4 this past week answering
a bunch of questions from the empire side of this
overarching story in the series what does moff
gideon want what is his grand plan what's going
on with the dark troopers and baby yoda's blood
the midichlorians that he's using in his cloning
experiments during that interview he teased a
couple big ideas that i'd never seen him or anyone
else talk about anywhere before these are a couple
of his quotes that i'm just reading here he says
when people flow out of control and there are
all these different moths who've been assigned
to different areas to be wardens of isn't there
one person or someone that may have guidance over
all them then he said those questions are answered
on the show and goes on to say what some of his
methods are in referencing the dark troopers
calling them super soldiers suggesting that
moff gideon wants to save the galaxy obviously
all villains think of themselves as the heroes
of their own stories he's like the gus fringe of
star wars but then he also raises another really
interesting question also why does moff gideon
know everything about what's going on everywhere
he has some kind of incredible intelligence
source so he's kind of implying that there are
other assets other big things of the big villains
out there other more powerful people in the galaxy
that we just don't know about yet grand admiral
thrawn is one of the few characters powerful
enough and smart enough to orchestrate galactic
events on the kind of scale that giancarlo
esposito is talking about and also think about
it this way it's kind of strange that moff gideon
seems like he's the big bad at least right now but
he's only using an artikin's class like cruiser as
his main capital ship instead of a full-blown
star destroyer i mean star wars loves to sell
new toys which is why they're always trying
to introduce new kinds of ships and characters
through the mandalorian like the razor crest but
there are a lot of different ways that you can
modify powerful capital ships like star destroyers
to make them feel different enough to make kids
want to spend money on them and for those of
you that didn't watch the clone wars or star
wars rebels tv series dave filoni is the one who
brought grand admiral thrawn back into official
canon after disney bought star wars originally he
was created by timothy zahn during the heir to the
empire trilogy of books back in the 90s i loved
reading those books so much because at the time
they were like the first big new star wars story
during a period in history when we thought that
we were never going to get more star wars movies
now if you watch that famous interview with mark
hamill during the 90s where he's talking about
george lucas's original idea for the new films or
what would have been his version of the new films
he at one time said would you consider playing an
obi-wan type character handing excalibur down
to the next generation i said when that would
that be and at the time he said around all around
2011. there was always the chance that those could
have happened but i think at the time most people
believed that there would never be more star wars
movies but thrawn's new canonical history borrows
a little bit from that original backstory in those
novels dave filoni changed a couple things just to
fit him in the new canon but thrawn was originally
an officer in the chiss ascendency naval fleet
he was always a brilliant strategist in the chiss
race rules most of this part of space in the
unknown regions right beyond the border of the
outer rim he met anakin skywalker during the clone
wars and then during the galactic reorganization
from the republic into the empire after revenge of
the sith he determined that an alliance with the
emperor was the best course of action to benefit
the chis people long term so playing the long game
of chess make all the chis puns that you want so
the emperor really wanted as much knowledge of
the unknown regions as possible so he wanted the
maps that the chiss people had and he recognized
what a brilliant strategist thrawn was then he
assimilates into imperial society and becomes a
member of the imperial navy quickly rising through
the ranks all of his campaigns were successful so
just one big win right after the other he
eventually gains command of the first fleet
in his star destroyer chimera he starts going
on missions with darth vader who he knew before
he became darth vader when he was still anakin
skywalker darth vader was actually the reason why
he started using the force dampening e salamiri
so that he had some way to keep him in check when
they were serving together on campaigns so that he
would not also be forced choked into oblivion he
was promoted to the rank of grand admiral by the
emperor there were 12 total grand admirals during
the emperor's reign grand admiral is a military
rank though grand moff like grand moff tarkin
was a civilian governor of the over sector of
space that covered a number of different sectors
each sector of space which contains a number of
systems a number of worlds was controlled by a
moth and there were about 20 mobs totaled during
the imperial era so moff gideon was one of those
20 moths at the end of that era his sector of
space that he was in charge of was obviously
the one where the mandalorian series mostly
takes place here in the outer rim so within
the hierarchy of the empire grand admiral thrawn
would be one of the few people more powerful or
higher up than moff gideon there is no grand moff
after the fall of the empire there was a member
of the imperial fleet named rand who promoted
himself to grand moff after the destruction
of the second death star in the aftermath novels
technically those are canon cobb vanth who we met
during episode 1 wearing boba fett's armor
he's a character from the aftermath novel
but the grand moff rand character basically fled
in an escape pod after his super star destroyer
was blown up in the battle of jakku so he's not in
power anymore he's not a threat during the events
of the mandalorian series the reason why thrawn
didn't die during the battle of endor the reason
why you didn't see him during the original trilogy
of movies is because during star wars rebels right
before the events of a new hope ezra bridger uses
the space whale's ability to navigate hyperspace
naturally to take thrawn and his fleet deep into
the unknown regions where they won't know how to
navigate because there are no hyperspace maps and
they won't be a threat to the rebellion anymore
because thrawn is one of those s-tier villains
powerful enough and smart enough to out-fox the
entire rebellion and new republic so that's why
at the end of the star wars rebels finale right
after the battle of endor in return of the jedi
in that end credit scene tag ahsoka tano comes
to pick sabine wren up another mandalorian by
birth by the way so that they could head into
the unknown regions and look for ezra bridger
because he was lost with thrawn for all those
years of the original trilogy so now that we know
that ahsoka has come back from the unknown regions
because she's in the outer rim the mandalorian
is taking baby yoda to see her it implies that
she was successful in finding ezra with sabine and
if ezra was last seen with thrawn it also probably
means that thrawn survived in the unknown regions
this entire time too you also have to keep in
mind that the chiss ascendancy don't control the
entire unknown regions but they do have a lot more
knowledge of them than other races of the galaxy
so of all the military leaders in the galaxy all
the most powerful people thrawn would be uniquely
suited to survive out there even if he started in
a part of space that was still unmapped the reason
why that's such a big deal by the way is because
you can't travel through hyperspace without the
precise mapping calculations otherwise you'd fly
through a planet or a star or a ship and you'd
be vaporized instantly there really isn't any
canonical story right now for exactly what thrawn
has been doing for the past several years between
a new hope in the events of the mandalorian series
but in the original novels the explanation that
they gave for how he survived the fall of the
empire was that he was on a mission for the
emperor mapping the unknown regions so pretty much
in both versions of this story the disney canon
the pre-disney legends eu canon he spends all
the time between the original trilogy of movies
out in the unknown regions mapping hyperspace
routes and gathering power before he returns
so the theory is is that we'll see him return
in the live-action series to be another big bad
between the events of return of the jedi and the
new star wars movies before the first order in
palpatine return there's a whole period of about
25 years for the mandalorian series and any other
new series set during this part of the timeline
to play in without having to change anything
big that they've established before in the way
they explain luke skywalker leia the new republic
during episode 4 this past week is that the
people of the core worlds where the bulk of
the new republic lives the main body don't really
pay much attention or mind to what's happening in
the outer rim like they don't believe that moff
gideon is a thing they just don't care about
any of the people in the outer rim which as you
would expect provides a lot of opportunity for
these larger characters like moff gideon grand
admiral thrawn any other villains they want to
introduce to come in and seize power to try and
mount another campaign to reunify the galaxy
under a new empire and if they decide to hold off
on thrawn and the mandalorian series they could
always introduce him in one of the other
live-action series with more of the star
wars rebels characters like live-action ezra
live-action sabine if they don't also appear
on the mandalorian eventually but post all your
theories in the comments when do you think that
we'll see a live action version of thrawn show
up first i've got a couple other bonus videos
my full mandalorian season 2 episode 5 video will
post on friday just like normal while you wait for
that click here for my brand new mandalorian
season 2 ahsoka tano video to learn what she's
been doing this whole time and click here for
my full mandalorian season 2 episode 4 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!